des milliers de supporters précéde
assister à la demi finale etats unis
angleterre mais les footballeuses du
sporting-club laventinois avenue de la
martinique aurait préféré voir les
anglaises affronter la france et leurs
idoles wendy renard très déçu parce que
celle qui nous représente en france 2 le
football féminin
c'est vraiment dommage qu'on puisse pas
la voie faisant contre mauvaise fortune
bon coeur la délégation profite
pleinement de cette opération parrainée
et financé par wendy renard et des
entreprises locales
elle assistera à deux demi finales et à
la finale de cette coupe du monde de
football féminin elles connaissent
toutes les stars qui sont à presque tous
les championnats européens et américains
mais c'est vrai que cette action-là va
valoriser le football féminin parce que
c'est vrai que c'est le parent pauvre du
football le football féminin et c'est
vraiment une opportunité pour nous les
parents n'ont pas décidé de passer aux
choses il ne l'aurait pas nous n'aurons
pas fait de cas nous nous sommes levés
nous allons démarcher
nous sommes allés de recherche des
entreprises que je remercie encore le
voit car ses enjeux
surtout cette opération n'aurait pas vu
le jour certaines ont pronostiqué la
victoire des états unis
d'autres plus revancharde ont souhaité
que l'angleterre remporte ce match mais
de la fausse osaka j'ai vu qu'elle
regrettait à prendre la revanche de la
france
installé aux premières loges elles ont
assisté à une rencontre intense remporté
par les états unis
exceptionnel
beaucoup de suspense beaucoup de jeux
beaucoup de bruit aussi mais beaucoup de
dégoût parce que la langue nationale pas
réussi à se qualifier et c'est assez
magique parce qu'il ya beaucoup de monde
il ya beaucoup de bruit et a beaucoup
d'émotion aussi c'est la première fois
que je vis un match comme ça les
martiniquais seront représentés leur île
ce week end dans un tournoi de foot
amical organisé par le football club de
lyon et assister à la grande finale de
la coupe du monde le 7 juillet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]